evil
swept across
uvalde yesterday
anyone who
shoots his grandmother in the face
has to have evil in his heart
but it is
far more evil
for someone to
gun down
little kids
it is intolerable
fox news alert we're getting brand new
details on the heartbreaking tragedy in
texas at least 19 children and two
adults are dead at robb elementary
school near san antonio police giving
more insight into how this terrible
event unfolded
jeff paul is on the ground with the
latest jeff
yeah jesse we're starting to learn more
not only about the shooting but also
about the suspect according to texas
governor greg abbott he says about 30
minutes before the shooting the suspect
sent some messages on social media now
in one of them he apparently wrote that
he was going to shoot his grandmother in
another he wrote that he did in fact
shoot his grandmother and then in a
third he wrote he was going to go shoot
up a nearby elementary school
investigators confirmed after shooting
his grandmother the suspect then drove
off crashing his truck near robb
elementary school from there officials
say he barricaded himself inside a
fourth grade classroom this is where all
21 people died 19 students and two
teachers now law enforcement then forced
their way in eventually killing the
suspect governor greg abbott made a
point to credit officers who responded
without hesitation
the reason it was not worse
is because
law enforcement officials
did what they do
they showed
amazing courage
by running toward gunfire
for the singular purpose of trying to
save lives
now shortly after making that statement
that news conference was then
interrupted by texas democratic
gubernatorial candidate beta or before
he was removed by police officers he
told the governor that he was doing
nothing and that this was totally
predictable jesse
jeff thanks a lot all right greg you've
had uh some time to think about what's
happened
want to share that with us well i mean
you know
this is terrorism and like terrorism
you find a way to prevent an attack
after it occurs right that's when you
see the variable that you missed if you
hadn't missed the variable then the
attack would have been prevented so you
don't hear about it so you don't see our
blind spots really until the
consequences occur from those blind
spots and i think we all are always
looking for one variable to explain
things for some it's racism others it's
lawlessness or gun control but i was
looking at the last four mass shootings
and it's
hispanic male white male black male
asian male all males
obvious but the one trait that doesn't
matter it's obviously race but there was
one strand beyond maleness and that is
mental illness and it may be the number
one problem in america um and this is
not a defense of the killing i'm just
trying to i look outside our streets the
killer and you see so many broken people
who aren't treated and then in rural and
suburban settings they may just be
tucked away and uh the the pandemic
makes it worse through isolation so we
have like a
a collection of aimless disturbed
mentally ill males and this in this case
the reason why he
wasn't prevented is age i mean they
we've kind of like been able to like our
mass killers are getting younger and
younger and younger because they don't
have a history and if it's like the
inverse of workplace violence there's a
that's decreased dramatically because
we're the ability to see a history of
violence in older males and then there's
more security but in this case they get
younger because those are the ones that
can get away with it because they had no
history he was able to buy a gun because
he had no criminal history and the only
time he posted on stuff was 30 minutes
before that's not enough time to act i
mean they tried but that is interesting
uh the mail component uh
being able to purchase the weapon
because your slate is clean and
missed warning signs throughout the
community throughout the family and
throughout the school martha yeah you
know i think greg makes a great point
about the um
variance in all of the people that we've
seen and then the things that they have
in common uh which is this mental health
issue right and i think back to i know
all of us when we started to learn what
had happened here yesterday you just go
right back to sandy hook because it it's
such a it has a lot of similarities
right you have this young man and i
think about um in adam lanza's case we
later learned that there had been
efforts to commit him uh that he was
afraid that his mother was going to do
that to him right and one of the things
that has totally broken down in society
is
that
option
okay the the option of relying on on an
institution a hospital where someone who
is not able to function in society can
go for treatment and what happened is
you know decades ago we decided that
these places were not
um we're not
we're not operating well right and some
of them weren't some of them were
absolutely horrific
um but the thing is that we started we
decided to mainstream everybody right
and medicate everybody so now you've got
this over abundance of people who live
out in
the public who maybe can't really
function that way it's interesting to me
i went on the website for the high
school and one of the things that we
learned is that he wasn't going to
graduate um and this is devastating for
someone his age
he worked at a wendy's where they
started to notice that his behavior
wasn't right kovid kept him home he
dropped out during kovid
this is another nexus that is really
important i think in this story in terms
of the isolation that was happening at
this point we don't know about his
parents there's some reports that his
mother had problems with drugs
but graduation is uh this friday night
at that high school right and there's
pictures on the website of all the kids
that are graduating and i and i heard
another reporter this morning to say
that they have pictures all up and down
the street in town because they're proud
of these kids that are graduating right
and uh this impact you know these are
not excuses these are just these are
just sort of what we look at as the data
points and the things that that perhaps
somebody could have picked up on um and
also and i know we're gonna talk about
this next block but we got to talk about
the school security issue because
there's a lot of questions they were
doing a lot in that regard that didn't
seem to be working no it didn't uh jeff
brought it up at the top beta o'rourke
crashed this press conference let's play
a little bit of that
he
[Music]
i'm sure you are outlined please leave
this auditorium
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
i've come to a deal like this to make a
political issue here
so the person who called them a sick son
of a
that was the mayor of the town this
happened at janine
well it's texas
and uh that was about as inappropriate
at a time when the governor was
recognizing the pain the grief the
healing that they're trying to begin
the fact that they have been traumatized
and will remain traumatized that small
town
for decades especially the children in
the school and for him to come and make
a political statement is such a cheap
political shot
and i believe he should have been shot
down for that this is not the time for
politics today is the time to recognize
the horror
that has been imposed upon this town and
these families and these victims and
it's a time to think about what we can
do so that no other child has to suffer
this kind of disaster or trauma again
but you know when we talk about mental
mental illness one of the things that
concerns me is it's just this kind of
amorphous blob mental illness the
buffalo shooter taught us that when
someone seems incapable of of
functioning in our society we send them
for a 7 30 which is what i used to do
when i was a judge if i thought someone
was a danger to himself or a danger to
others i would send him for a
psychiatric review now they're doing the
psychiatric review they're letting them
out the guy in buffalo goes out and
kills 10 people the guy who traveled to
buffalo i should say and you know a lot
of these people are not necessarily
mentally insane this is not insanity
insanity is when you don't know where
you are you're in a totally in a state
where you can't tell time or relevance
or what's going on this guy's predicting
what he's going to do he's saying i just
did it now i'm going to go do this so
the question for us today is how we can
come together and heal the pain for
everyone i don't care if you're a
progressive or you're a right right-wing
person i don't care what you are we all
bleed i'm a mother and a grandmother and
i bleed for this kind and agree for this
kind of trauma i don't we all imagine it
happening to our loved ones so one of
the things we have to do is we have to
make sure that we start prosecuting
crime and i'm not going to be political
here i want to prosecute crimes i want
to prosecute gun crimes i want to know
and we'll talk about this in the in the
next block the crumbs there were some
crumbs we know that he's from a broken
home
we know that he's a loner we know that
he was self-injuring himself we know
that he was made fun of because he has a
lisp and because apparently he wore
eyeliner we know that there was violent
rhetoric from people he worked with and
that he was isolated
i mean you know but does that mean we
can go out and arrest him no
so let's not just throw it out at mental
health let's try to harden the
facilities which we'll talk about in the
next block geraldo the judge makes a
really important point say you send
someone to a psych ward and they're not
insane they're evil they're a sociopath
how do you address that
i don't know
i think that
we have to
come to grips with the fact that there
is mental illness in every country on
earth
but these mass homicides
with rare exceptions are an american
phenomenon
every country has crazy people why is it
here that they result in such slaughter
but i just want to say a different thing
i want to go in a different direction
because i am sorry and ashamed that we
haven't done more to protect to protect
these children and i was listening to
jeff paul's
our correspondence report just that
and he talked about how
all of the fatalities were from that one
classroom
so there's 19 children and two teachers
so
regardless of the kind of weapon you
have you know it takes time you got to
shoot shoot shoot
so imagine the terror
that these children in that room are
feeling when this
animal
is now
killing them he's barricaded himself in
their classroom now he's killing them
and he kills johnny and he kills sarah
and he kills mikey and this and that
i
cannot
fathom the terror
that these children endured
i mean
for that
all of us there's no ideology there's no
difference left right we all parents
grandparents the nature of the way we
feel we s what is
how is the human
being capable of that kind of despicable
heartless
it is
yeah yeah it's uh it's beyond
description and very emotional for
everybody involved hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else